Produkterna är inte speciella men de är bäst på det de gör.
All sak, trafik och dejt.
När jag tittar på Jimkompaniiet så kan man säga att ni har en dominans i SEO.
Du är fortfarande snäll här.
Men det kommer ju.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsätt den under 60 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Ni har inga sura kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med, men vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Aida Jamal till podden och det är kanske en av mina mest önskade gäster.
Du är ju sjukt skärpt, jag tror att rätt många har hört dig i framtidens e-handel, jag tror att jag har lyssnat på varje avsnitt där tre gånger eller något sånt där.
Men sen har jag ju faktiskt träffat dig ut en gång också, vi sågs via en bekant och då kände jag fan, du är ju också rätt rolig, annars tänker man ju att investmentfolk är rätt tråkiga.
Skulle du beskriva dig som en rolig person?
Jag tror mina kollegor skulle beskriva mig som en rolig person.
Jag tycker inte att jag är så där rolig men jag är ju väldigt ärlig, jag vet inte om det finns någon koalition där.
Jag är väldigt dålig på att ha filten när jag snackar och säger oftast det jag tycker och tänker.
Ibland kan det upplevas roligt tror jag.
Men jag har inte en sån som har skämt.
Jag förstår inte sarcasm alls.
Men jag tror att det är att jag säger precis det jag tänker.
Det gör ju att folk blir väldigt hockade ibland och förväntar sig inte att man ska göra det.
Det gör ju att man kan upplevas lite rolig och skön kanske.
Det är kul för jag tycker att det finns många fördomar mot folk i finans.
Det har jag förstått.
Jag tänkte säga det.
När jag läste din bakgrund där så står det Investment Banking Warwick Business School.
Bara det namnet låter som från någon gammal österrikisk tråkig novell typ.
Och så nu är det equity här men kan man liksom ha en personlighet när man jobbar inom den här branschen eller suddas det ut och så blir man någon sorts kameriont eller översittare?
Jag tror absolut att det väldigt lätt kan siddas dit.
Jag tror att om man jobbar i väldigt corporate miljöer att man på något sätt slutar vara sig själv, utan man blir väldigt vikantig.
Och så kan jag vara faktiskt under min London-tid när jag jobbade inom banking.
Men sen jag flyttade till Sverige och jobbade på IECORI, det finns ju rätt så många unika personligheter här och alla välkomnas med sina unika personligheter.
Jag känner att jag kan få vara mig själv här mycket mer.
Men absolut att jag var mer vikantig när jag jobbade inom banking i London.
Och jag förstår att det...
Jag har ju på något sätt ett CV som matchar en sådan som...
Jag körde banking i år i London och jag gick liksom en av de här sex skolorna som man ska gå i England för att komma in i bankingvärlden.
Jag var ju inne på flashbackforumarna när jag var i gymnasiet och bara såhär, vad ska man pugga för att komma in i banking?
Ja detta är liksom din grej.
Det här är min grej, ja.
Jag har ju planerat det här sen andra året i gymnasiet att jag skulle hamna precis här jag är idag.
Och det är ju väldigt kanske ovanligt, men sen har det så klart inte varit spikrakt hela vägen, men det är ju väldigt väl planerat.
Och jag var ju aldrig inne på att jobba inom finans, utan jag gick ju naturvetenskap i gymnasiet och är man utlänning med högst betyg så ska man ju bli läkare eller ingenjör.
Så jag var ju väldigt inne på att bli läkare.
Och jag gick den här sommarforskarsskolan hos Karolinska institutet där på andra ring och det var då jag insåg att jag vill absolut inte bli läkare, det passade inte mig.
Så då var jag faktiskt inne på flashbackforum och jag bara såhär, vad gör man när man har riktigt bra betyg och inte vill bli läkare?
Liksom, då pluggar man industriell ekonomi på KTH eller så blir man konsult på McKinsey eller så jobbar man inom investment banking i Yorker London.
Och det var då jag bestämde mig för att det är precis det jag vill göra.
Det låter kanske väldigt märkligt men det var sexskolor man skulle gå på i England.
Jag ville jättegärna plugga utomlands, det har alltid varit min dröm.
Jag ville faktiskt plugga i USA egentligen men hade inte råd med det.
Så det fick bli England istället och det funkade jättebra.
Tyckte jättemycket om det.
Och Warwick var ju en av de här sexskolorna som man skulle gå i England för att ha i alla fall störst sannolikhet att komma in i Banking.
Sen är det fortfarande en ansökansprocess och hela den biten.
Det är ju väldigt få som kommer in i den världen.
Jag tror det är successrate på 0,5% av alla som söker in.
Så det var ju många intervjuer.
Man hade många internships som man var tvungen att ta.
Man skulle nätverka med rätt personer.
Det är mycket som ska stå rätt till ändå, trots att man går rätt skolor för att hamna där man vill hamna.
Vad är det du är duktig på då?
Eller varför tog de in dig i de här ena av 200?
Jag skulle inte säga att jag har någon överintelligens, men jag är väldigt disciplinerad.
Jag har alltid varit bra på att plugga.
Det är väl det som har tagit mig hit.
Jag har alltid haft väldigt bra betyg.
Jag kommer verkligen från ingenting.
Jag kommer från en liten håla utanför Hälsingborg som heter Mörarp.
Jag har ett utlängdsbakgrund, kommer absolut inte från pengar.
Inget i nätverk i den här branschen whatsoever.
Så jag har pluggat mig upp för att bli städd på något sätt och det blev jag väldigt tidigt redan i högstadiet.
Så var det ju väldigt uppenbart att jag hade väldigt bra betyg och jag skulle inte säga att jag var mer smart än någon annan, men jag var extremt duktig på att plugga.
Alltså det låter väldigt tråkigt men det är ju så man tar sig ur där man är och det är därför jag rekommenderar alla ungdomar att plugga sig ut till det elandet man har eller vad det nu är.
Det säger jag inte att det var det jag hade men om man nu upplever att man inte är där man vill vara i livet, att man försöker plugga sig eller jobba sig ut på något sätt.
Kan du känna ett förrakt för sådana människor som mig som jag är rätt dålig på att plugga?
Och jag lever ju väldigt mycket på magkänsla eller sen har jag ju en känsla för siffror såklart och har alltid haft men men jag har väldigt svårt att sitta ner och plugga.
Det är liksom inte, jag kan inte tänka att jag har pluggat ett eller andra prov någonsin.
Nej, jag har ju många, alltså mina syskon var ju likadana och jag har absolut inte att jag är fördomsfull men jo men jag skulle ändå säga lite faktiskt.
Alltså om man är i, om man är liksom, om man lever ett liv som man inte är nöjd med och klagar, då finns det sätt att ta sig ur.
Jag menar inte att man behöver plugga men det ökar sannolikheten för att man slipper leva som man gör.
Om man faktiskt får, alltså det låter så tråkigt men om man utbildar sig och om man pluggar, det underlättar bara så mycket.
Och det öppnar så många dörrar.
Och jag skulle bara säga, oavsett vad du gör, var bäst på det du gör.
Om plugget är den vägen du ser, det var den vägen jag såg i alla fall, för att jag skulle tjäna mer pengar, vara mer bekväm, vara självständig framför allt.
Det var ju framför allt det som var min största drivkraft när jag var ung, att jag skulle bli självständig.
Och det var min väg ut.
Sen skulle det absolut kunna vara någon annan väg man hade kunnat hitta.
Jag har ju väldigt mycket respekt för entreprenörer, det är säkert därför jag och många entreprenörer, vi blir ju vänner till slut.
Jag känner väldigt mycket, många entreprenörer har ju samma drivkraften, att man vill vara chef av sitt eget liv, att man vill känna sig fri, att man vill välja sin egna tid eller vad det nu är, och vara självständig.
Det är precis samma drivkraft som jag hade.
På så sätt har vi mycket gemensamt.
Jag och du Joel, trots att du inte pluggar det, men jag pluggar det.
Det här var min väg ut liksom, och du är ju uppenbarligen bäst på det du gör.
Annars hade du inte tagit dig ditt, och den har den friheten du har.
Men du tilltalades aldrig av att driva bolag?
Jo, hela tiden.
Absolut.
Hade jag inte suttit här, hade jag nog drivit bolag.
Så det skulle vara min väg ut.
Men det är ju mycket risker.
Och jag tror att när man kommer från en familj där man inte kanske uppmuntrade sig att ta mycket risker, vilket jag faktiskt inte, det var ingen stor utmuntran, när jag växte upp, utan man skulle ta minst risk faktiskt.
Och då blev man exakt en sån som jag då.
Alltså någon med kanske ett bra jobb, och bra lön och bra utbildning.
Men man önskar ibland att man tog lite mer risker.
Det är absolut något som jag har i åtanke.
Skulle du säga att du är låst nu?
Man säger ofta att det är bra om man är ung och inte har något att förlora, för då är det lätt att starta bolag.
Men sitter man i en, du blev ju nyligen partner här, det kanske inte är ett jobb man bara, fuck it jag startar något jävla klädvarumärke här.
Alltså det är ganska svårt att påstå.
Det är hundra procent svårt.
Och det är ju, man blir ju, jag brukar säga att man blir lite låst i sin egen framgång.
För att man blir ju väldigt bekväm.
Och jag känner in ändå att jag är chef över mitt eget liv.
Hundra procent annars hade jag inte varit kvar där jag är.
Och det är därför jag nu har varit på Eko det är sex och ett halvt år.
För att jag känner att det här passar mig väldigt bra.
Och jag får driva de projekten jag driver.
Och jag känner absolut inte att det är någon chef som andas mig i nacken.
Och har aldrig känt, trots att jag är partner idag så har jag aldrig känt så.
Utan det är väldigt bra teamwork här.
Och det är därför jag väl hittat någonstans där jag kan få vara lite entreprenör men ändå.
Vad innebär partner?
Innebär det att man har en del av firman då?
Precis, partner innebär ju att man är delägare.
Och egentligen har ju alla här på Eko det är ju delägare i båda fonder.
Så alla har ju aktier i båda fonder.
Men alla anställda har det?
Alla anställda har det.
Och det har jag också alltid haft sen dag ett.
Och det är ju för att man vill skapa alignment och incitament såklart.
Så om det går bra för fonden ska ju alla här gynnas av det.
Och det är väl inte superovanligt.
Större fonder kanske inte brukar ge aktier till juniorpersonal.
Men är man en mindre fond så är det mer normalt att alla får ta del av kakan.
Men vad det innebär att vara partner, ska jag vara helt ärlig, för min del så har det från day to day inte ändrats alls.
Och jag tror att det är ett bra tecken.
Det innebär ju att man alltid liksom, eller att man rätt så naturligt har kommit in i den här rollen.
Många tror ju att det är mycket som har förändrats.
Men jag jobbar ju på, precis som jag gjorde innan.
Jag tror att den största förändringen faktiskt för min del är att vi precis har ökat tid med time turned.
Och det gör ju att jag kan delegera ännu mer än vad jag kunde göra innan.
Det är den största skillnaden skulle jag säga för min del.
Och som partner så klart så blev man ju chef över personal som kom in här.
Och det har absolut gjort stor skillnad för mig.
Men hade vi inte haft det så hade jag fortsatt jobba på som jag gjorde innan.
Och precis som alla andra vd-ar och entreprenörer, vid något tillfälle behöver man ju lyfta blicken och jobba mer strategiskt.
Och det har jag ju såklart gjort i många år men nu kan jag göra det ännu mer.
Och det är ju väldigt skönt.
Så det skulle jag säga är den största skillnaden.
Men vad är ditt jobb egentligen?
Är det att träffa entreprenörer och försöka hitta bra?
Jag skulle säga att det kallas sourcing då.
Att man är hit och sourcer eller scoutar bolag.
Och det gör jag absolut.
Så att jag träffar entreprenörer, jag skulle säga minst varje dag träffar jag någon entreprenör som vi inte har investerat i eller har något samtal eller någonting.
Eller något tilläggsförvärv vi vill titta på.
Och det behöver inte alltid bara investering från Ecori.
Utan det kan också vara vår portföljbolag som vi tycker att det finns intressant energi i ett annat bolag.
Så varje dag finns det någon touchpoint med en ny entreprenör, ett nytt bolag.
Men det är ändå en liten del av faktiskt vad jag gör.
Utan majoriteten av min tid läggs på att jobba med bolagen.
Alltså värdeskapande initiativ, allt från rekrytering till IT, till kan man sätta upp optionsprogram, det kan vara tilläggsförvärv, det kan vara allt från titta på siffrorna, prata med bolagen om vad som sker i marknadsföringar eller vad som hände i de olika...
Alltså det handlar ju mycket om att man får bra data såklart och att man tittar på det varje månad.
Och sen så har man touchpoints med entreprenörerna och ser över vad det är man behöver titta på.
Just nu är det väldigt mycket snack om att vi för till exempel ska...
Det har varit väldigt mycket tullsnack i USA.
Det har tagit mycket tid.
Det har varit väldigt mycket snack om...
Använda att öppna upp i nya marknader.
Det har varit väldigt mycket snack om att...
Fortsatt faktiskt att man ska bli om överlager.
Det kan vi prata i flera timmar om, men det är fortfarande ett problem i vissa bolag att vi snurrar laget lite för långsamt.
Binder lite för mycket kapital.
Jag lägger också min tid på att använda...
Nu har vi precis fått in en checkkredjurt och det behövdes lite arbete inför det.
Till en bank.
Jag har precis gjort en ny emission i ett annat bolag.
Det är ju vi som leder många av de här projekten.
Jag har precis...
Var finns det mer rekryterat in en ny vd i ett bolag?
Jag bara känner att det räcker nog med uppgifter där.
Ja, precis.
Men jag skulle säga, majoriteten av min tid läggs på värdeskapen.
Det ser jag till vid bolagen.
Det är det absolut viktigaste och det är där vi är unika för att vi lägger extremt mycket tid på att bolagen ska gå bra under tiden vi investerar, alltså under vår investerings tid.
Ja, för det är egentligen en av mina stora sådär funderingar.
Nu kan inte alla era olika namn här, men det finns ju lite olika bolag som investerar i företag och för oss...
Jag fattar att ni alla känner er jätteunika.
Ja, det här är våran grej.
Men liksom, för oss på andra sidan så framstår ni alla ganska samma.
Finns det på riktigt nischer?
Det här är equity jävligt bra på, det här är worth it, jävligt bra på, det här är, alltså vad är det?
Ja, men det skulle jag ändå säga.
Sen när jag är i branschen så är det väldigt lätt för mig att säga och jag kan helt förstå att det känns som att alla är likadana.
Men i equity är vi ju en sektorfokuserad fond, och bara det är ju enikt, vi fokuserar ju bara på digitala bolag.
Mycket är i handel, vi är ju väldigt kända för att ha gjort många investeringar i handelsbolag och många av våra bolag är väldigt kända.
Så jag skulle säga att det är ju det första som gör oss enika, att vi fokuserar bara på det, på en bransch i princip.
Sen har vi ju allt från logistikbolag i Gordon till exempel, till en graviditetsapp till prisjakt, till traditionella i handelsbolag som Chimmy, Amen, Kids Brand Store, John Henrik och så vidare.
Så det är ändå rätt brett fokus, men vi älskar ju digitala bolag och det kommer ju från grunderna.
De har ju startat ett internetbolag förut.
Och det är också en annan grej som gör oss rätt unika, det är ju att vi är inga, det här står i en D-artikel också att jag sa så, men vi är ju inga typiska finanslistar.
Jag blev lite obekannad till att det står så stort det där.
Men egentligen finns det inget annat sätt att beskriva det som, men att vi är ju väldigt entreprenela i teamet.
Och vi tänker väldigt mycket entreprenellt.
Och vågar ta risker.
Vi vågar öppna butik i USA, vi vågar göra tilläggsförvärv som kanske andra inte hade tänkt på, och så vidare och så vidare.
Och vi vågar få handla och vi hittar kreativa lösningar.
Så att vi är ju väldigt kreativa, skulle jag säga, entreprenörs, vänliga, och vi är fokuserade på en sektor.
Så det är väl det som gör oss unika.
Är de andra företagen inte entreprenörskreativa?
Jag tror att du måste fråga entreprenörerna.
Vi har ju haft entreprenörer som har haft flera investerare, bland annat Ecorio, San Verdeino och andra typer av investerare.
Och jag tror att de skulle beskriva oss som att vi är, det var faktiskt en, jag vet inte vad det var, svensk namn, han sa att vi är mer rock'n'roll.
Och det innebär, tror jag, vad han menar, att vi är, som jag sa, vågar tänka lite mer utanför boxen.
Sen vill jag också säga att vi har ju alltid, vi vill ju inte hitta nästa Spotify eller Klarna, det har aldrig varit vår strategi.
Det är inte de riskerna vi tar, utan vi vill ju hitta bolag som växer på ett bra sätt med finlandsamhet.
Vi vill ju inte att bolag ska växa hundra procent varje år om det innebär att det skadar landsamheten.
Och vi har ju absolut exempel på bolag i vår portfölj som har kanske haft lite för mycket fokus på just tillväxt.
Och det är mycket för att andra investerare som har varit med i CapTabern har kanske drivit den frågan.
Men det är aldrig någonting som vi trycker hårt på.
Ni har inte den här spray and pray-grejen att nio av tio ska gå i konkurs och en ska bli gånger hundra.
Ni försöker medfåra alla och fem exa under era tid.
Ja men någonstans trea till fem ex.
Jag skulle säga att tre ex är fortfarande väldigt väldigt bra.
Och det innebär ju att vi investerar i bolag som omsätter hundra miljoner och vi vill sälja bolagen där de har omsätt en halv miljard.
Och då ska helst EBITDA vara någonstans när vi kommer in 20, 30, 40, till hundra liksom.
Så det låter väldigt mycket lättare än det här.
Det är faktiskt extremt svårt att växa EBITDA från de nivåerna till hundra miljoner plus.
Det är inte många bolag som ligger där.
Är det inte lite svårt att få entreprenören att köpa in på?
Ni säger inte kunder, vad säger ni?
Portföljbolag.
Ja, säg att ett bolag kommer till er och så köper de in på er grej och de tycker om er.
Men då vet de att om fyra år så ska ni lämna och så ska de hamna någon annanstans eller så.
Det måste vara ganska konstigt för även om man gillar er så ska man gå med på att fem år är ju inte så jätteligt.
Jag har ju varit på gymcompanyt i 14 år och ägt i 10 år.
Fem år för mig är en jättekort tidshorisont.
Många entreprenörer vill ju också göra en exit ihop med oss när vi sen ska sälja och då funkar det ju väldigt bra.
Och det lättaste är ju faktiskt att man säljer bolaget ihop.
Att man gör en stor exit ihop tillsammans med entreprenörerna.
Sen absolut, jag håller med dig, många vill ju inte det.
Men då kan man ju hitta andra sätt till exempel att man, att bara vi går ur, vi säljer vår andel.
Men oftast vill ju entreprenörerna också sälja.
Det skulle bli förvånad över hur många det är som faktiskt vill vara kvar men ändå säljer en stor andel.
Och det är ju en tuff resa man har gjort med Ecorie under de här fem åren.
Alltså att fem-dula sitt bolag, det är många gråa hårs då, är liksom senare.
Många ser ju faktiskt fram emot, jag skulle säga exit är det mest spännande många entreprenörer tycker.
Alltså de älskar att prata exit med oss.
Vi har ju sådana här workshops, vi har dagar där vi reser ihop med entreprenörerna, vi var i Sandholm för några veckor sedan.
Och så har vi olika workshops, vi hade genom törle, genom hur man förbättrar vinst och så vidare.
Och sen så handlar det om exits.
Och den hade ju flest, det var ju flest som satt i det, för många är ju nyfikna på hur det går till och det kytlar i magen för många entreprenörer att göra exits av deras bolag.
Oavsett om de vill vara kvar eller inte, det är helt okej att vara kvar.
Men jag tycker, jag tror att man ändå gynnas av att, att samarbetet skulle vara enklare om man också vill sälja efter e-query.
Jag tror att det skulle underlätta mycket och de flesta vill ju också sälja en stor del.
Är vi så enkla som människor?
Alltså, ja faget, och här fick du de här pengarna, så gör det här nu.
Jag bara tycker att det känns, vad gör folk sedan?
Jag vet inte vad folk hittar på.
Jag vet inte om det bara är pengarna Joel, men jag tror att det handlar om att man, man är trött tror jag, absolut, och att många känner att de inte vill göra samma resa igen.
Säg någonsin nej till bolag för att ni ser att grunderna är förslutna.
Hela tiden.
Bara förra veckan träffade jag ett bolag som, jag kände såhär, de vill bara köpa tis i Spamien, att det ändå är för dig, och leva ett rätt så bekvämt liv, och det är helt okej, men under tiden i Eko är en investerare i ett bolag, det är inte kanske det mest bekvämaste.
Sen är det mycket som förändras som är positivt för en entreprenör.
När vi kommer in så säkerställer vi att entreprenören har en ledningsgrupp, och det är ju den största skillnaden.
För många av entreprenörerna, när det kommer till day to day, de har ju helt plötsligt ett helt team de kan bolla med också, och det är ju superviktigt för oss att att det inte är en entreprenör sitter på för många hattar.
Det är för riskigt liksom och det är inte så man skalar.
Så jag vill också bara ge dig den andra sidan, att när vi Eko det kommer in så jobbar vi i det gärna.
De jobbar på ett annat sätt kanske, vad de har gjort, eller det är i alla fall målet att de ska jobba på ett annat sätt än vad de har gjort tidigare.
Vi kan inte ha en entreprenör som också sköter marknadsföring och personalansvar och inköp, utan vi måste ha spetskompetens i de områdena.
Och det tycker ju många är superskönt.
Och när vi kommer in med en påset hänger in i bolaget så vågar man ta de riskerna man vågar anställa.
Och det är också ett misstag som många entreprenörer sen själva inser att de har anställt för juniorpersonal eller att de inte har vågat anställa överhuvudtaget.
Och här kommer vi då in och bara såhär borde din ledning skupt sig ut.
Det blir inte ganska mycket skav.
Jag bara intalar mig själv att ganska många entreprenörer bygger upp sitt bolag.
Om man är ett bootstrappat bolag så kommer man ju ha juniorpersonal från början.
Och man kommer ju att ha en viss kultur eller ett visst sätt att jobba.
Och många sitter på många hattar för det är ju så man överlever i början.
Ni måste ju rätt ofta vara med om att första året efter att ni investerar blir rätt kaotiskt och inte alls tillväxtaktigt utan det är bara massa nya kostnader innan man kan på riktigt ta iväg.
Det måste vara rätt vanligt eller?
Hela tiden, det är vanligt absolut.
Det har ju varit en kamp ibland att faktiskt övertyga entreprenörer om att de behöver en CFO och sen när de väl får en CFO, wow.
Det är ingen skillnad det gör.
Och oj vad de tackar oss.
Så jag tror ibland att det handlar om att man inte vet vad man inte vet.
Om man inte vet hur det är att jobba med en mer senior person som kanske kostar lite mer eller att man inte vet hur det är att outsourca så vet man inte vad det betyder.
Så att liksom, jag skulle säga att 10 av 10 fall har det varit positivt.
Sen har vi absolut haft entreprenörer som känner att nu har vi byggt på oss ett för stort kostnadskostym och då går vi tillbaka och säger antingen behöver vi skala tillbaka då eller så får vi växa ännu snabbare.
Är det den i särklass största röda flaggan om ni märker att folk inte kan ta input?
Vi investerar inte i bolag som inte har coachable entreprenörer och vi lägger väldigt mycket tid på att säkerställa att den här entreprenören vi kommer jobba med fem år vill ta inputs från oss.
Men fejkar inte folk det?
Jo, men vi gör personlighetstester, intervjuer, alltså externt, vi outsourcer det.
Vi gör HRD det med alla nyckelpersoner i bolagen.
Oftast handlar det om en till fyra personer och vi får väldigt mycket information.
Vi får en rapport på hur det faktiskt är och de är väldigt intressanta de rapporterna och ger oss väldigt mycket information.
Men det är därför man som investerare behöver ha magkänsla.
Man behöver ju ha en känsla för personer.
Jag kan oftast se det där väldigt tydligt.
Till exempel, jag har träffat entreprenörer som är väldigt passionsdrivna och de vill till exempel att alla ska ha påsökkläderna som man själv skapar eller vad det nu är.
Och det är en väldigt grön flagga för mig.
För det innebär ju att man har en vision och det är väldigt viktigt som investerare att känna att entreprenörer man investerar i vill något mycket större än där de står idag.
Och det brukar vara en av de första frågorna vi ställer i ett första möte.
Vad är din dröm väl bolaget?
Vad vill du om fem år?
Vad vill du att bolaget ska vara?
Och vissa säger såhär, vi vill väl takta på lite som vi har gjort, kanske lite bättre, bara få lite stöd.
Eller vissa säger nej men jag vill omsätta en miljard.
Jag ger mig inte.
Och man ser det på entreprenörer.
Vissa säger, jag behöver inte citera, men man märker det väldigt tydligt tycker jag.
Tidigt i processen är det svårt att fejka det.
Även om man fejkar det i början så brukar det ofta komma ut.
Det är ju många sessions man sitter ihop liksom.
Har ni good cop, bad cop, folk som kommer in?
Folk som är sociala extroverter, folk som är introverter?
Jag skulle säga, vi partners i alla fall har väldigt bra magkänsla.
Jag skulle säga att vi alla är bad cops.
Nice, yeah.
Nej men alla är ju...
Ni har ju inte ljulampor här som ni bara lyser i ansiktet på folk.
Alla har olika infallsvinklar.
Men jag skulle ändå säga att vi alla, efter så många år, efter så många möten, men för entreprenörer kan snabbt bestämma oss om det här är intressant eller inte.
Finns det några exempel på...
Alltså ganska ofta fastnar man ju så här i hur bolag är.
Det är ju klart att bolag ska tjäna mycket pengar, de ska vara lönsamma och de ska skala, de ska finnas på en massa marknader.
Jag fattar allt det där.
Det är lite halvlogiskt på något sätt.
Men finns det vissa personlighetsdrag, och så entreprenörer som är verkligen green flags, som ni verkligen, det här går vi igång på, det här gillar vi.
Jag skulle säga att passion för produkterna är någonting som jag har upptäckt att man kommer långt med.
Det är lite som jag beskrev innan, att man vill nåt stort med sitt bolag.
Att man vågar ens tänka och drömma stort.
Bara det är en stor grön flagga.
Sen kan jag också ge tråkiga svar som att om man vet hur mycket lagret snurrar, och vad man har för G-MET 2.3, det är absolut vissa att man har lagt sig in dem.
Är inte det ett måste, eller investerar ni någonsin i entreprenörer som inte vet vad det är som man innehåller på?
Absolut, men då brukar man ha någon som kompletterar igen i rummet.
Jag kan inte ha produktiva möten med entreprenörer om de inte vet vad deras gemet 2-3 är, eller i alla fall gemet och landsamhetsbottomline.
Man helst att de också vet lite marketing metrics.
Det här är för att jag skulle kunna göra en snabb analys.
Men de bolagen vi investerat i, de har ju oftast inte stenbra koll i början, men de lär sig under processen.
Så jag skulle aldrig hoppa av om någon inte kan svara på alla siffror och frågor under ett möte.
Men på något sätt behöver vi ju ta reda på det.
Så länge vi får tillgång till datan så kan vi ju ofta göra det.
Men jag skulle ändå säga att många av bolagen har ju two co-founders, och det brukar alltid vara en som är den kreativa, produktnöden, och den andra brukar vara den som är lite mer affärsmässig och kan svara till exempel på hur it är nu.
Är det så stereotypt?
Det är faktiskt väldigt mycket så, har jag upplevt.
Och jag tycker att den kombinationen är viktig, vill jag säga, och jag tror att det är nog anledningen för varför det är de två som sitter i rymma med oss, för att de har uppenbarligen tagit sig upp till en viss nivå.
Och den liksom, jag tror att det är nyttigt att vara två, eller man behöver inte vara det, absolut inte, man kan vara en och man kan vara tre eller mer.
Men jag tror att det är bra att man kompletterar varandra och det underlättar extremt mycket.
Men när IECO investerar, vi gör ju en DD-process och man känner ju väldigt tidigt att du kommer inte kunna svara på alla frågor eller, ja det kommer vara jobbigt och extremt distraherande och det är ju oavsett om man är sifferkunn eller inte.
Men man behöver ha koll på businessen och jag vill ändå säga faktiskt, när jag började på IECO för sex och ett halvt år sedan, så var det en viss nivå på mötena med entreprenörer.
Idag är det på en helt annan nivå.
Alltså nivån har verkligen höjts.
Alla pratar ju GM1, 2 och 3 nu för tiden.
Alla vet ju att GM2 är efter frakt och så vidare.
GM3 är efter marknadsföring.
Alla pratar kosta av sale och kack nu för tiden.
Har bra koll på A och VR, X och ink moms.
Så jag skulle säga att nivån har blivit mycket högre på entreprenörer.
Jag tror att poddar har haft väldigt mycket med det att göra.
Det har varit en extremt stor fördel.
Jag märker att entreprenörer säger rakt ut att jag lyssnar på de här poddarna, men märker under möten att de gör det.
De är extremt kunniga och har lärt sig helt enkelt.
Skulle du säga att du har blivit ett dragkloster för er?
För igår så var jag på e-handelsdagen här då stod jag och pratade med en massa olika e-handlare och då var det folk som frågade om poddern och då sa jag att jag skulle hit och intervjua dig.
Det var ju väldigt glada myner, alla visste ju vem du var och har ju lyssnat på de här avsnitten.
Men det betyder ju att folk känner till ett namn och känner man till ett namn så är det ju en sån person man letar efter.
Det betyder ju bara att det är lättare att kontakta dig än någon annan här.
Upplever du att du har blivit så?
Absolut, hundra procent det skulle jag säga.
Jag har ju poddat, inte jättemycket men lite.
Den feedbacken man har fått, jag har blivit hockad.
Det var ju tack vare poddar som jag och du.
Jag tror jag skrev till dig första gången när jag hade din podd på Framtidsenjhandeln och jag tyckte att du var sjukt grym på den.
Jag är också själv faktiskt bra på att skriva till dem som jag tycker är duktiga.
Precis som alla andra, de skriver väl till dem de tycker är duktiga.
På så sätt så bildas det, det skapas en klick i handelsarna och nördar som du säkert upplever med någon annan för du är i den själv.
Jag tycker att jag förespråker att man ska utbilda andra eller berätta om det man kan.
Det är någonting vi på EECO gör hela tiden varje dag.
Om det är något bolag som är extremt duktiga per CEO eller som har fått till en bra förhandling med något faktbolag eller vad det nu är.
Vi är extremt duktiga på att förmedla den informationen till andra eller introducera folk till varandra.
Vi har ju forumar för olika avdelningar i varje organisation.
Allt från kundtjänst till HR till ekonomi.
Där vi bara såhär, nu ska ni träffas och sitta här i ett rum av två timmar och vi har i agendan.
Och det gör vi liksom varje månad.
Jag är en sådan person, det har gett mig extremt mycket att lyssna på andra.
Och jag tror att andra upplever också att det har gett mig vattenfördel att lyssna på mig.
Och det är såhär, jag tackar liksom ödmilt.
Men det är liksom mitt sätt att ge tillbaka för att jag själv lagt mig jättemycket genom att sitta med entreprenörer eller lyssna på deras poddar.
Jag tänkte, nu går vi lite åt andra hållet här men jag tyckte att det kunde vara kul att få höra lite hur ja men hur ni tänker mer logiskt.
Jag tänkte att vi skulle rollspela här på ett försök till ett jätte icke-cringe-igt sätt.
Men om jag hade kommit till e-equity här nu, ja vi omsätter ju ungefär 100 miljoner nu, vi omsätter väl 110 i år kanske.
Men bara så att folk är med på liksom begränsningarna i detta.
Vi ligger på en magentoplattform som inte alla människor gillar.
Jag är ensam ägare så vi är inte två olika människor, så vi har ju massa bara juniora människor.
Jag finns inte i Stockholm, vi gör ju ingen vinst.
Vi går med vinst men det är ju väldigt liten vinst.
Och vi har ju ganska trög, rörligt material.
Det är liksom ingenting som omsätts tio gånger per år.
Men om jag kom till er och så säger jag så här, tja jag skulle tycka att det var kul att få in massa pengar här så att jag kan skala upp, för jag vill femväxa det här på fem år.
Jag säger exakt de här vackra orden.
Vad hade dina ifrågasättanden av gymkompaniets blivit då?
Ja, jag vill börja med att säga att jag är skitimponerad över vad du har åstadkommit med bolaget.
Vi köpte det för tio år sedan för nu omsatte vi två miljoner eller någonting och nu är vi uppe i hundra.
Men om vi skiter i allt snällt och så går vi bara på bad cop?
Vill du bara ha bad cop?
Okej.
Nej men du, det är ju en tuff bransch att vara i.
Det är ju väldigt prispressat.
Det är en rätt sovkommortatist produkt.
Alltså det är ju svårt att stycka ut genom produkterna och då behöver man ju säkerställa att man i alla fall har någon sorts volym i saktrafiken eller liksom, jag har ju tittat på en del bolag som liknar gymkompaniet och sådär såhär ja men produkterna är inte speciella men de är bäst på det de gör.
Det är liksom all saktrafik går dit.
Så att ni, när jag tittar också över på gymkompaniet så kan man säga att ni har ju en dominans i SEO.
Du är fortfarande snäll här.
Men det kommer ju, det kommer.
Så att, prispressad bransch så att man behöver säkerställa att man har en stark position och det har ni ju.
Men om man tittar på de sakerna som jag tycker är liksom lite red flags i caset så skulle det ju vara i så fall att ni har ju väldigt låga vinst där just nu.
Sen förstår jag ju varför, såklart.
Ni har ju väldigt höga faktkostnader bland annat.
Brytto-marginal på någonstans 43 procent.
Och vi har ju fler bolag i vår portfölj som har brutto-marginaler på de nivåerna men som ändå har lyckats få lite högre lönsamhet och det är ju för att de har lägre faktkostnader än vad ni har.
Sen har ni säkert andra kostnader.
Jag tittade bara lite snabbt på resultaträkningen.
Ni har ju 36 procent av omsättningen i Other Opex och det ingår ju frakt.
Och jag vet inte hur mycket som är frakt av den delen versus allt annat.
Men det är ju extremt högt.
Det är extremt högt.
Frakt är säkert majoriteten av de kostnaderna.
Sen är ni överlag väldigt slimmade.
Ni är bara 5 procent av omsättningen i personalkostnader.
Så att väldigt slimmade men det är ju, jag har det djupdygt i vad finns det för potential i att få ner fraktskostnaderna eller höja A och V in och mer för att man ska få med i landsamheten ett par år.
Men är det en sån, om jag bara stannar där då, säg ett sånt bolag som vårt som, ja men vi har ju liksom en bedrövlig frakt.
Vi har ju dels att vi måste dra allt på container och då försvinner ju, redan vid införsäljtillfället försvinner ju en, så blir det ju en ganska dyr per krona eller vad vi ska säga import.
Och sen så har vi en när vi skickar ut och vi har dessutom dyrare turer även om vi är i en bransch med väldigt låga returer.
Men i ett sånt här case, hade ni då undersökt och kollat, ah, det finns andra bolag som säljer tunga grejer, vi ser vad deras fraktpriser är, och så gör ni den jämförelsen.
Är det så ni kollar eller?
Vi benchmarkar ju.
Nu har jag ju inte din data i ett split liksom, så att jag kan benchmarka, men det skulle jag göra om jag skulle uttrycka i caset och då skulle jag se vad ligger i effektiviteten någonstans.
Och jag skulle gissa att det är frakt hos dig.
Och då behöver vi ju...
Sen är ju frakten så här tråkig.
Alltså det är ni inte alltid...
Man kan absolut spara några procent på det, men det finns inte jättemycket att hämta oftast där.
Och det är oftast ett volymspel i så fall, för att det vet du mer än en annan, för att man ska hämta in mycket frakt.
Men absolut att det skulle vara någonting jag skulle uttrycka i.
Och så är det ni som har dåliga fraktavtal, eller är det någonting med ledtiderna, eller någonting annat.
Alltså kan man katta med den män på något sätt, för att sänka den kostnaden.
Och nu kan jag ju inte bolaget så bra, men det skulle ju vara någonting jag skulle titta på än.
Du sitter inte på höga lån, vad jag kan se.
Möjligt att du har en check, svårt att veta.
Så att liksom, i ett nettokassa, eller vad man ska säga perspektiv, du har inte jättemycket kassa, nu tittar du verkligen bara på april.
Vi gör ju detta.
Jag skulle säga absolut att den röd flagga i ditt bolag är att du har för hög kapitalbindning.
Det är en tråkig sak i bolag.
Man vill ju inte broskas med likviditet, för det är en sån begränsning.
För oss, om vi skulle komma in redan, i början behöver vi broskas med det här, utan vill man ju ha en hälsosam likviditet på något sätt.
Sen vill jag ändå säga att många bolag som växer snabbt, vilket du ändå har gjort.
Du växte 23 % 2024, 22 % 2023.
By the way, under tuffa år, det vill jag ju ändå ge dig komplimanger för det.
Det är ju en tuff marknad, inte så många flytt och så vidare, och det är säkert då du säljer mest.
Så du har ändå lyckats växa.
När man växer har man oftast ett negativt kastaflöde, vilket innebär att man växer lagret i snabbare takt än när man tjänar pengar, väldigt förenklat.
Och det ser jag ju att du gör, och det behöver inte betyda att det är en mega red flag, utan det innebär egentligen bara att du har återinvesterat allting tillbaka din tillväxt.
Och det ser jag ju i siffrorna att det är det du har gjort, jag hoppas det stämmer.
Och det är ju ingen red flag, men det innebär bara att hade du bara haft lite mer lönsamhet så att du kan täcka den tillväxten själv, så hade det varit ännu bättre.
För då hade du inte behövt binda så mycket i laget.
Och ett sånt metric, för det är ju lagomsättningshastigheten, hade du slurrat laget snabbare så hade du inte behövt binda så mycket kapital, och du hade bara sålt snabbare och inte liksom haft ett så negativt kassaflöde.
Väldigt förenklat språk här, men jag tror att det är lättare att förstå.
Nej men jag tycker det låter jättelogiskt för att det är ju exakt det som är våran, jag bara hoppas att alla kan uppskatta att jag valde att ta 15 minuter av tiden här bara till att få en masterclass i vad jag gör fel, så att jag kan gratis utnyttja de här råden.
Men det är exakt det som är, alltså vi har ju haft likviditetsproblem sen dagen jag köpte Juncompani.
Det är ju alltid det som är våran, när folk säger, vad är er största problem?
Att vi inte har pengar.
Det har ju alltid varit besparingsproblematiken att vi inte har, vi har inte möjlighet att köpa in rätt saker, men vi hade kunnat köpa rätt saker ännu mer, vi hade kunnat växa, vi har aldrig haft problem att växa, för det är alltid att vi har för lite av det som vi ska sälja.
För vi har inte träckligt med pengar för att vi har så långsamma inköp, och vi måste köpa minimum-
och ordukvantiteter som efter covid steg absurdt.
Så det är ju så här, det ser ut i det här.
Det är sanningen, och det är ju inget ovanligt problem, men sen finns det så här som vd, det finns olika fokus att du kan ha.
Jag kan tänka mig att det fokuset du har haft under alla åren, det är bara så här att överleva i princip, och liksom växa stadigt.
Och när jag menar överleva så menar jag så här, att du har kassa för nästa dag i princip, och du nyckels.
Och det är, jag tror så här, om det finns sätt för dig att öka din bruttomarginal, jag vet att det är supersvårt.
Vi har ju haft ett ganska bra år nu när dollarn har gått ner, så det har ju varit ett väldigt trevligt år, inköpsmässigt.
Men jag tror att mycket hänger, för du har extremt slimmad organisation, det ligger nog inte i det.
Jag tror inte du har så mycket kostnader, utanför, jag tror inte du har så mycket OPEX egentligen.
Utan det är ju framförallt frakta, tror jag inte du kan spara jättemycket mot vad du redan har.
Men det är säkert volymspel, och jag upplever att du är svinbra på att förhandla, svårt att se att du sitter på de sämsta avtalen i alla fall.
Jag tror att mycket för dig handlar om att få mer vinst för varje krona du tjänar.
Det kommer att trilla ner och göra det mycket enklare för dig.
Finns det branscher som är...
Det är som du säger, ett av våra stora problem är att en hantel ser allt ut som en hantel.
Vi kommer inte göra en unik hantel, vi kommer inte göra det, eller en viktskiva igen.
Den kommer alltid att se ut som en sån.
Finns det branscher som är oinvesterbara för att de andra tio bolagen som säljer den där, vi kommer ju alltid slåss om samma viktskiva.
Jag har inget ont av det, jag bara menar att det är så här, vi kommer inte kunna höja priserna över en viss nivå för att då är det inte, vi kan höja med några procent för att kunderna uppskattar en viss grej, men vi kan inte gå högre än det, för det är inte värt det.
Det finns ju begränsningar i produkten som du gör.
Jag skulle inte säga att det är oinvesterbart för att så här, om man har en produkt som är väldigt commoditized, det är så dåligt på svenska men det innebär ju att det finns många liknande produkter.
Det innebär ju då att det blir väldigt mycket prispress, och det är ju en bransch som vi vill i alla fall inte vara där.
Sen har vi några portföljbolag som absolut har rätt så prisprestade produkter, så det är ingenting som jag aldrig har sett.
Vi har ju investerat i vissa branscher, till exempel djurfoder, som är ju superprisprestat.
Men även där har vi haft en strategi om att öka private label på så sätt, och massa andra saker som vi har gjort för att öka marginalen.
Det är ju väldigt tufft.
Jag skulle säga att det enda sättet för investerare att tycka att det är intressant, det är ju att man har majoriteten av volymen i branschen, trots att det är en sån produkt som många köper.
Jag har träffat ett bolag, jag vet inte om jag kan säga namnet, men de säljer väldigt chockiga produkter för fötter.
Allt möjligt, fotsilor, fotkrämor, fothälsa.
De tyckte jag var skitspännande, för att de var nummer ett på allt vad gäller det.
På grund av det hade de väldigt hälsosamma marginaler.
Trots att det egentligen, jag tror faktiskt inte, det var inget private label, det var bara produkter som de köpte in från Kina.
Men de hade skapat en nisch och lyckats bygga ett community kring det.
Och då blev det väldigt intressant.
Så i ditt fall så handlar det om att få mer vinst för varje krona sälj.
Och det kan du ju få genom att öka återköpsfrekvensen återigen.
Jag vet att det är svårt.
Du har ju varit väldigt öppen med att du är emot CRM och den typen av metoder som man använder.
Är det en stor red flagg att man har entreprenörer som, vad ska man säga, livear företag?
Ja alltså den enda röda flaggan i det är ju att du, och vilket jag har sett nu, du är ju öppen för att prova.
Och det är ju super positivt.
Jag gillar ju att när entreprenörer går efter, mindre efter markkänsla och mer efter data, då vet jag att vi kommer jobba bra ihop.
Så länge du, och datan säger ju, jag kan ju säga, jag säger ju bara genom att väldigt high level tittat på ditt bolag, att du skulle må bra av att ha en högre återköpsfrekvens.
Du skulle må bra av att få mer vinst för varje krona du säljer.
Är det något bolag som inte hade mått dra av det?
Nej, ingen.
Jag menar, vi gör inte allt vi kan för att uppnå det.
Det gör ni säkert Joel, men jag tror att jag hade i alla fall tittat på det ännu mer och försökt bygga kanske ett community runt ditt bolag och bygga ett skydd mot det.
Nu är ju produkterna super generiska, men skyddet kan det ju vara att du har byggt en lojalitet, enligt community.
Vi har ju flera bolag, jag menar vi har ett bolag som säljer träningskläder, det finns ju hur många bolag som säljer det, men de har ju byggt ett community nu runt det.
Det är ju spänn liksom.
Det är ju det som gör att bolaget blir så högt värderat.
För att de har ju investerat i varumärket.
Varumärket är ju en grej och produkten är en grej.
Och såklart ska det hänga ihop, men ibland så gör det ju inte det.
Man har ju träffat bolag som säljer vatten för sjuka priser.
Men det är ju för att de har byggt sitt brand.
Och det skulle jag säga, sen kostar det ju pengar men du har ju gjort det nu på senaste tiden, på ditt sätt, genom att du har blivit så.
En hel foppis i branschen tycker jag det är absolut ett sätt att bygga brand.
Men att du kan göra det ännu mer, jag tror att du skulle må väldigt bra.
Jag tror att ditt bolag skulle må bra av det långsiktigt, att bygga något sorts.
Du kan vara så här, the go to place för hur man använder gym i ett skap.
Jag skulle verkligen behöva det, även om jag inte har ett hemmagym eller vad det nu är.
Du behöver hitta sätt att nå majoriteten, även om dina produkter inte gör det.
På så sätt tror jag att du kommer att bygga ett community, och du om någon kan göra det.
Du blir liksom the place to go to för gymutbildning.
Tänk så.
Jag vet att du är emot att kränga och sälja, men om du tänker så istället så tror jag att det har en väldigt fin ripple-effekt.
Det hade jag varit mer krydd på.
Jag tänker att man ska nog aldrig ta företagare för seriöst när de säger att de är emot att sälja saker.
Det är nog lite bullshit.
Alla företagare gillar nog att sälja saker.
Det är en av de dej vi vill alla sälja, och det är det viktigaste.
Får jag fråga en annan?
När ni går in i ett bolag, då vill ju ni höja värdet på bolaget.
Vad är det viktigaste där i att höja värdet?
Hur höjer ni värdet på ett bolag?
Är det omsättning, är det vinst, är det att det inte ska finnas några risker i bolaget?
Vad är liksom de stora...
Det finns ju två faktorer.
Man får inte glömma en faktor, och det är ju marknaden.
Och den sätter ju värdet väldigt ofta.
Ett värde av ett bolag är också väldigt ofta utanför din kontroll.
Det handlar ju om hur beteendet är, hur apetiten är för den branschen.
Den faktorn är ju oftast inte jättelätt för oss att kontrollera.
Och det har ju, nu ska jag inte prata i en marknadsupdate, men det har ju varit tufft för konsumentbranschen historiskt, eller i alla fall sen efter covid.
Det har ju inte varit den sexigaste branschen för investerare att vara i.
Och det innebär ju också för oss att det inte är superlätt att sälja.
Och för många andra som har investerat i vår bransch.
Så det är ju att påverka värderingen, det är ju utanför din kontroll.
Den andra faktorn som absolut påverkar, eller är inom din kontroll, det är ju hur du exekutar din affärsmodell.
Och det är ju alla de här sakerna vi har pratat om.
Att du bygger värde i ditt varumärke.
Att du har lojalitet, att du har nöjda kunder.
Att du har en produkt eller ett varumärke som många gillar.
Och så vidare och så vidare.
Och hur vi bygger värde rent för att ge riktiga exempel, det är ju såklart genom tillväxt.
Skala bolagen, skala dem lönsamt.
Bygga en kohort som kommer tillbaka kvartal efter kvartal.
Vi bygger framför allt mycket värde genom att öka vinsten.
Alltså om jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Speciellt nu mer än någonsin så är ett värde på ett bolag sätts ju på en multipel på vinsten.
Förut var det på försäljningen mycket mer, skulle jag säga.
Men idag behöver man få upp en vinst.
Är det fortfarande så?
Det är väldigt mycket så.
När vi byter, byter vi på vinst.
När vi säljer potentiella köpare lägger vi en multipel på vinsten.
Sen vill jag ändå säga såklart att det finns bolag som har väldigt låg vinst men ett extremt fint brand.
Jag tycker att Byredo brukar vara ett exempel.
De hade ju knappt någon vinst.
Det finns andra bolag, nu vill jag inte slänga dem under bussen, men det finns ju många bolag som har haft sjukt höga värderingar trots att de har låg vinst.
Men för, om jag...
Jag kan ju ta upp exempel men vi hade ju CDLP här som omsätter inte så jävla mycket, vill jag minnas, men säger att de omsatte 60.
Jag hittar på lite här, men jag vet att de gick ganska mycket minus för jag reagerade på det där när de sålde och jag för mig att de fick ganska hög värdering.
Och jag är ju en sån här tråkig människa.
Vi har ju aldrig gått med förlust även om vi inte gör så mycket vinst så går vi alltid med vinst.
Så jag vill gärna växa men jag vill ju växa så att jag går med vinst.
Och jag tycker att det är väldigt svårt att förstå.
Det här är ingen sån där grej utan jag har väldigt svårt att förstå hur man värderar varumärket.
Jag kan inte riktigt se.
Jag håller med dig, det är supersvårt.
Än idag är det fortfarande svårt för oss som är en ändå rätt så viktig spelare i den här branschen och helt hittat helt rätt där på hur man mäter varumärkeskännedom.
Man kan ju titta på organisk trafik såklart, branded search, man kan titta på återköpsfrekvensande, det säger väl någonting om varumärket och så vidare och så vidare.
Det finns såklart metrics som ger en bra bild om man tänker en data.
Men jag tror liksom exempel som CDLP och Bayerero, jag tror att även Kimi faktiskt i vår portfölj har lyckats få väldigt höga värderingar.
Jag tror att det är lite av en, jag tror att det är coola brands.
Det är många affärsänglar som går in och man vill kanske förklippas på något sätt med det brandet.
Jag tror att det är brands som, sexiga, coola brands som har fått investerare utmärksamhet och de lyckas få bra värderingar.
Men om man tittar i bolagen så är det inte, långsiktigt är det ju inte hållbart att driva bolag med så låg vinst.
Eller jag vet inte hur just CDL passer ut idag, men många av de bolagen sitter också på väldigt höga lån, vilket innebär att de har ju växt på grund av att de har lånat pengar.
Det är absolut inte långsiktigt.
Så att man ska vara väldigt försiktig som investerare i vad man går in i och man ska inte stära sig blind på att vissa bolag har fått höga värderingar.
Ska jag vara helt ärlig, ibland kan det handla om en trend.
Det har vi inte ganska ofta om än.
Jo, det handlar väldigt ofta om en trend och ibland så är det en viss sektor som är väldigt het.
Där flera bolag i den branschen får väldigt höga värderingar.
Utan att det egentligen finns en smart grund i det.
Och när man tittar på bolagen så är de oftast väldigt såbara rent finansiellt.
Så att man ska vara väldigt försiktig med det.
Det är väldigt enkelt för ett bolag att slänga massa pengar marknadsföring.
Men det handlar ju om att man säkerställer att det finns en långsiktighet i allt man spenderar och har man inte det tänket så existerar man oftast inte väldigt länge faktiskt.
Fan jag har kommit till fråga två av 30 men vi ska ta typ två minuter till men det var inte alls det jag tänkte ha som slutfrågor men nu fastnade vi där.
När ni får ett varumärke, lägger ni ändå en värdering på varumärket och så får man betalt för det varumärket.
Gör ni så eller kollar ni på hårda fakta?
Nej jag skulle inte säga att vi sätter en separat värdering på något sätt på varumärket.
Det skulle jag inte säga.
Helt brand är värt 15 miljoner.
Ni gör inget sånt.
Nej när vi värderar bolag, vi tittar på två saker.
Vi tittar på, precis som alla andra investerare, det här är verkligen ingenting ovanligt.
Utan man tittar på, man gör en COMP-analys, kallas det Comparables.
Man tittar på bolag som liknar det här bolaget på börsen.
Och så sitter man med, det är väldigt enkelt att se vad bolag på börsen värderar det till.
Så då gör man liksom, man hittar någonstans fem till tjugo bolag som är mest relevanta i den branschen.
Vad är de värderade till?
Så får man ett snitt.
Det berättar ju någonstans vad det bolaget är värderat till.
Det andra sättet vi tittar på värderingar, rent faktormästligt, är ju att titta på fördelen av transaktioner som har skett i branschen.
Så att man kan ändå skapa sig en känsla, utan man kan rent faktormästigt titta på data.
Vad är bolaget värderat till på börsen?
Men då värderar ni liksom inte varumärket i sig, utan ni värderar hur liknande bolag, vad de får för multipel.
Ja, väldigt förenkla.
Sen kan man säga så här, men det här bolaget växer snabbare, så det borde ju från premium.
Eller det här bolaget har de här begränsningar, det borde få en debatt.
En sån här begränsning kan vara att man till exempel bara finns i Sverige, versus de andra bolagen man tittar på.
Men när jag skickar ett byd till en rådgivare så behöver jag oftast ha argument för det, och då använder jag den här datan och sen så lägger jag en premium eller en rabatt på det.
Fan, Aida vi hade som sagt kunnat köra på rätt mycket mer, men jag ska inte uppta hela din dag här.
Ett enormt tack för att du var med på den, skitkul.
Vissa avsnitt är bara för mig.
Så jag har typ fem sådana avsnitt som jag bara har gått och snackat med för att jag vill ha massa info.
Så ni andra får bara hoppas att ni fick med i någonting, men jag bryr mig inte jättemycket.
Tack så jättemycket för att du var med.
Inga problem, tusen tack.
Hur ni tänker, mer logiskt.
Jag tänkte att vi skulle rollspela här.
På ett försök till ett jätte icke-cringeigt sätt.